Hi, I'm Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know, your life is different now.
I'm here with Mamrie Hart and Hannah Hart
They are mimes today
I figured you'd zoom in, put some like applause sound effects
This old song and dance
These old so and so-es
(Dramatic sound effects)
Today, we got a real
Simple video for you
[Deep voice] What? Oooh.
It's March and Saint Patrick's Day happens in March and for the last I don't know how many years on various YouTube channels
I've been shotgunning beers on St. Patrick's Day
My tab moved!
Goose no! Goose no!
No Goose, no!
No. No. You can't, no beer for Goose!
Mamrie: I drank it all.
I didn't even open my tab yet.
But I thought let's switch it up a little bit because in reality none of us really drink beer.
True
You know...
You used to. You used to love beer
I still love beer
Beer to me, is the, you know, the partner that makes you feel like s*** about yourself
I once bonged a beer funnel that came from a second story
This year we are switching it up
and it feels like lately every time you guys are on my channel I just make you participate in some sort of game
So, we have a game today
Yay!
A game that I'm calling, "Vodk-HUH?"
Huh?
I like that. Yeah, yeah, that's usually how I feel about the next day. Yeah, I'm all what did I do last night? Drank Vodk-huh??
And the rest is just a blur. We are all very big fans of vodka soda
So I thought you guys might be really good at this game in which you guys are gonna blindly
Tasting four different vodkas and you're going to see if you can tell which brand of vodka it is
Because I am very very low level taste in vodka
But a lot of people have really high level or top-shelf taste in vodka and to me they don't taste any different.
Maybe you guys might be able to figure out if they do. This will be good
because Mamrie is always good at everything. She knows the taste of everything, the nuance of everything. She's competitive.
She does it all, but Mamrie doesn't like straight vodka. Room-temp vodka, I'm not an 80 year old Russian man
Also...
So stop leaving those comments. Yea, yea, yea
So get off my dating profile. What I'm not good at is knowing the difference between
Tastes like in expensiveness.  Grace, remember when we were in New York
Yeah, and someone gave me a sip of like 80 year old wine. Like a, like a
$3,000 bottle of wine and just came over and gave me a sip, cause it was my birthday
It was during "Dirty 30" promo
and I went "this taste like shoe dirt"
Yea!
And he was like, "that was $400 you just spit on the ground right now"
Mamrie: So I'm not good at this. Ok. Grace: I'm basically just making you place this game right now because I wanna play this game
I'm just excited to get started. I've contributed no commentary because I'm like "do they taste any different?"
So we'll start with number one. It's your first glass here. Mamrie: so we don't know the list of brands? We just have to guess the brand
Well would you guys wanna know the list of brands? Hannah:No no no no, okay? I can't smell anything
That's good that's a sign of vodka. I think it's a sign of either goodness or cheapness
I'll put the four bottles here that I uh bought
Belvedere. Whoa, you splurged. Tito's at the lower end. Stolie's also. And Skye. Okay. Well, I personally I feel like that
Personally, I actually feel like that. Grace: I looked at the prices. Tito's and Skye are the same price.
And Stoli is second.
You're fooling yourself Stoli. Yea please. Work on your packaging. Cause that looks like sh*t. And also this is plastic.
This is glass
But these are also airplane bottles. But look at that intricate drawing okay
Belvedere's. Stoli. Tito's, and Skye
Number one: have a sip
Which one do you think it is? I'm getting no nose. It's not wine. Is this a wedding reception because I'm getting no bouquet
I think it's got a little bit of a crispness to it. The finish is short
The finish is short. You can describe it all you want. But I have no idea what any of these would actually...
Did you say each round, or can we go through
I think we should go through and then guess.  So you wanna taste all of them... Mamrie: and then we say our thing
So that's your first one. Okay, wait, so I ha, let me think. There was definitely a peppery-ness to it
No scent and a very short finish for me. Okay.
Did you just give your tinder profile?
On to number two. I'm going to get so red on this video. The whole video's just gonna be black and white the whole time don't worry
Or just sepia toned.
This might be my Tito's guess
I think this might be my "Teet"
Move on to number three. Let me just keep track. But Grace? No I'm just sipping, randomly to see if they taste different.
Are you subconsciously sipping the ones that we're on? I honestly don't know. Oh please she just wants a shot.
Okay, now began to realize [that] I could doesn't really smell like anything in general. Yeah
Also, if you guys need palate cleansers, cause I feel like it might be a little bit
Nope? Ok. So number three got you good! Huh...Number three...Number three, you guys are having two very different reactions to number three.
I'm a vodka drinker. I like vodka.
I enjoy vodka, but come on number three could start a f****** monster truck with one flick.
I'm sorry, I don't understand what you said. Northern California versus North Carolina.
I mean, I went to high school parties with straight up white lightning and that thing just made me...What's white lightning? Moonshine! Oh, moonshine!
Ready number four! Uh-oh, wait a minute. Old friend? Or foe?
She just drooled all over herself!
You just broke up with that old friend! I hate it!
Guys, we have drank all of these vodkas!  No, number four is bad. Try it Mamrie. You threw up.
Thank you for that clickbait thumbnail. You're welcome.
It's terrible, but...
You guys go ahead, place your bets, make your guesses.  Belvedere, Stoli, Tito, Skyy, got most expensive to least expensive
There's no way to do this oh
Wait, so these are yours from...?
Okay, I got mine. Oh wait, no no no. Wait, wait wait. Wait, hold on, I'm not...
Hold on, let me cleanse my palate too.  Oh wait, okay, don't move these! I won't, yeah. I have mine. I think row positioning makes no sense.
I don't understand. We say what we think number one is yeah, okay?
What do you think the first one was that you sipped? Belvedere. Tito's. You can't change your answers just so you guys know. Yup. Number one is skyy.
You thought it was Belvedere?  That was the most expensive one. WAIT!
No. F*** I f***** it up.
The first one you drank was skyy vodka which is the cheapest vodka!
I like this skyy best.  In order of my... wow. Okay, so what... No my system is flawed, you're correct.
Yeah, I told you. I can't remember what is what. Okay, what do you think the second one was that you drank? I shoulda... I thought that number two was Tito's.
I thought number two was Belvedere. Number two was Belvedere.
I have one point! You have one point. What did you think number three was?I thought number three was Stoli. Wait, what did I do?
Hold on, I thought that was... (mumbling)
Number three yeah, I thought that one was Stoli.
No no no, sorry sorry, I thought three was Skyy. Number three was Tito's. Yeah, I had that wrong. I had them all wrong!
Four, Stoli. Which one did you spit out?
I spit out four!
Four, Stoli, is what I have. What'd you have? I have four as Skyy. Four is Stoli.
(Gasp) I got two right! I am good at everything!
But it's also more expensive than to Tito's and Skyy. Oh my gosh
I enjoyed Skyy the most, probably cuz it's mostly water. Oh wait. They have the same alcohol content. [oh] So one can't be mostly water.
They're all forty percent alcohol content. They just have a different distillation. [oh], I do think Belvedere is very good
My two favorites were these guys. Maybe I should switch to Skyy instead of Tito's.
These are my two faves.
Yeah, I like Tito's. But Mamrie, you won and this is your gift, it's a Price Is Right scratch off! (Cheering)
Can I play it right now? Yeah, I actually do want to see if you win cause I spent $5 on it.
I think I have some quarters in that tit jar. Do I have any quarters in here? Do I just go for all of it?
I got nothing.  I don't know how to play play. Play area on right to uncover 18... an 18 wheeler... 18 real numbers.
We may have to cut back to it. I don't know how this works. You won $200! No...
We'll come back to this.
Follow us on social media to see if Mamrie actually won this scratch off ticket.
And make sure you go follow Mamrie and Hannah on YouTube because we shot two other videos on their channels.
They're really fun. Hopefully this was helpful to you
I think we might have did this completely wrong
So uh, congratulations to future Grace editing this video, I'm really proud of you for making it to this point. Good luck with your, Vodka?
I don't know
(Mumbling) just like and she's got one really low boob. Awkward proportions happening right now?
Don't worry. If there was a clothing line called Awkward proportions. I would buy everything oh
I won't react, let me just look up what it actually is.  It's, uh, it smells like, uh...
Cinnamin buns or rolls. I'm roasting the squash for us. Oh good.
God, you just brought so much elegance to this video. (Laughter) I'm roasting the squash for us! I can't wait. It's not a metaphor.
I'm a Belvedere girl! Who knew!? I'm a Skyy.
And this one can suck all the d***s. F*** you Stoli. I mean, no,  there goes all made possible brand deals